so the first question that comes out of
course is that whenever you see machine
learning or you hear about machine
learning it seems to be like this magic
wand your boss says put machine learning
into your application or if you you hear
about startups they put machine learning
into their pitch somewhere and suddenly
they become like a viable company but
what is machine learning what is it
really all about and particularly for
coders what's machine learning all about
actually quick show of hands if any of
your coders yes I oh I guess pretty much
all of us right are coders I do talks
like this all the time and sometimes
I'll ask how many people are coders and
three or four hands show up so it's fun
that we can geek out and show a lot of
code today so I wanted like talk about
what machine learning is from a coding
perspective by picking a scenario can
you imagine if you're writing a game to
play rock paper and scissors and he
wanted to write like something so that
you could move your hand as a rock a
paper or a scissors the computer would
recognize that and be able to play that
with you think about what that would be
like to actually write code for you know
you'd have to pull in images from the
camera and you'd have to start looking
at the the content of those images and
how would you tell like the difference
between a rock and a scissors or how
would you tell the difference between a
scissors and a paper that would end up
being a lot of code that you would have
to write and a lot of really complicated
code and not only the difference in
shapes think about the difference in
skin tones and male hands and female
hands large hands and small hands you
know people with gnarly knuckles like me
and people with nice smooth hands like
Carmel and so how is it that you would
end up being able to write all the code
to do this it would be really really
complicated and ultimately not very
feasible to write and this is where we
start bringing machine learning into it
this is a very simple scenario but you
can think about there are many scenarios
where it's really difficult to write
code to do something and machine
learning may help in that and I always
like to think of machine learning in
this way think about traditional
programming and in traditional
programming something that has been our
bread and butter for many years all of
us here were coders you know what it is
is that we think about expressing
something in expressing rules in a
programming language like Java or Kotlin
or Swift or C++ and those rules
generally act on data and
out of that we get answers like in
rock-paper-scissors the data would be an
image and my rules would be all my f
ends looking at the pixels in that image
to try and determine if something is a
rocket paper or scissors machine
learning then turns this around it flips
the axes on this and we say hey instead
of doing it this way where it's like we
have to think about all of these rules
and we have to write and express all of
these rules in code what if we could
provide a lot of answers and we could
label those answers and then have a
machine in fair the rules that map's
once or the other so for example in
something like the rock paper and
scissors we could say you know this is
these are the pixels for a rock and this
is what a rock looks like and we could
get hundreds or thousands of images of
people doing a rock so we get diverse
hands there are skin tones those kind of
things and we say hey this is what a
rock looks like this is what a paper
looks like and this is what a scissors
looks like and if a computer can then
figure out the patterns between these
and can be taught and it can learn what
the patterns is between these now we
have machine learning now we have an
application we have a computer that has
determined these things for us so if we
take a look at this diagram again and if
we look at this again and we replace
what we've been talking about by us
creating rules and we say okay this is
machine learning we're gonna feed in
answers we're gonna feed in data and the
Machine is gonna infer the rules what's
that going to look like at run time how
can I then run an application that looks
like this so this week we're gonna call
the training phase we've trained it
what's gonna be called a model on this
and that model is basically a neural
network and I'm gonna be talking a lot
about neural networks in the next few
minutes but what that neural network is
you know we're gonna wrap that we're
going to call that a model and then at
run time we're gonna pass in data and
it's going to give us out something
called predictions so for example if
I've trained it on lots of rocks lots of
papers and lots of scissors and then I'm
gonna hold my fists up to a webcam it's
gonna get the data of my fist and it's
gonna give back what we like to call a
prediction there'll be something like
hey there's an 80% chance that's a rock
there's a 10% chance it's a paper and
10% chance it's a scissor something like
that so a lot of the terminology and
machine learning is a little bit
different from traditional programming
we're calling it training rather than
coding and compiling we're calling an
inference and we're getting predictions
out of inference so when you hear us
using terms like that
that's where it all comes from it's
pretty similar to stuff that you've been
doing already where traditional coding
is just slightly different terminology
so I'm gonna kick off a demo now where
I'm gonna train a model for rock paper
and scissors the demo takes a few
minutes to train so I'm just gonna kick
it off before I get back to things so
I'm gonna start it here and it's
starting and as it starts to run I just
want to show something as it goes
through so if you can imagine a computer
I'm gonna give it a whole bunch of data
of rock paper and scissors and I'm gonna
ask it to see if it can figure out the
rules for rock paper and scissors so any
one individual item of data I give to it
there's a one in three chance that gets
it right first time if it was purely
random and I said what is this there's a
one in three chance that would get it
correct as a rock so as I start training
that's one of the things I want you to
see here is the accuracy that out like
the first time through this the accuracy
was actually it was exactly point three
three three sometimes when I run this
demo it's a little bit more but the idea
is once it started training it's getting
that random it's like okay I'm just
throwing stuff at random I'm making
guesses of this and it was like one in
three writes as we continue we'll see
that it's actually getting more and more
accurate the second time round it's now
53% accurate and as it continues it will
get more and more accurate but I'm going
to switch back to the slides and explain
what it's doing before we get back to
see that finish can we go back to the
slides please okay so the code to be
able to write something like this looks
like this this is a very simple piece of
code for creating a neural network and
what I want you to focus on first of all
are these things that I've outlined in
the red box so these are the inputs to
the neural network and the outputs
coming from the neural network so I love
talking about neural networks at i/o
because at i/o input output and you'll
see I talk a lot about inputs and
outputs in this so the input to this is
the size of the images those are all of
the images that I'm going to feed to the
neural network of rock's papers and
scissors are 150 square and they're
three by color debt and that's why you
see 150 by 150 by three and then the
output from this is going to be three
things and because we're classifying for
three different things a rock a paper or
a scissors
so always when you're looking at a
neural network those are really the
first things to look at what are my
inputs what are my outputs what do they
look like
but then is this mistake
yes thing in the middle where we've
created this TF torque eros the layers
are dense and there's a 512 there and a
lot of people wonder what what are those
512 things well let me try and explain
that visually so visually what's going
on is I'm going to what those 512 things
are in the center of this diagram
consider them to be 512 functions and
those functions all have internal
variables and those internal variables
are just going to be initialized with
some random States but what we want to
do is like when we start passing the
pixels from the images into these we
want them to try and figure out what
kind of output based on those inputs
will give me the desired output at the
bottom so function 0 is going to grab
all those pixels function 1 is going to
grab all those pixels functions who is
going to grab all those pixels and if
those pixels are the shape of Iraq then
we want the output of function 0 1 & 2
all the way up to 511 to be outputting
to the box on the left at the bottom so
stick a 1 in that box and similarly for
paper you know if we say ok when the
pixels look like this we want your
outputs of F 0 F 1 and F 2 to go to this
box and that's the process of learning
so all that's happening all that
learning is when we talk about machine
learning is setting those internal
variables in those functions so we get
that desired output now those internal
variables just to confuse things a
little bit more than machine learning
parlance tends we call parameters and so
for me as a programmer it was hard at
first to understand that because for me
parameters are something I pass into a
function but in this case when you hear
a machine learning person talking about
parameters those are the values inside
those functions that are going to get
set and gonna get changed as it tries to
learn how I'm going to match those
inputs to those outputs so if I go back
to the code and try to show this again
in action now remember my input shape
that I spoke about earlier on 150 550 by
3 those are the pixels that I showed in
the previous emulating them here with
gray boxes but those are the pixels that
I showed in the previous diagrams my
functions now is that dense layer in the
middle those 512 so that's 512 functions
randomly initialized or semi randomly
initialized that I'm gonna try to train
to match my inputs to my output
and then of course the bottom those
three are the three neurons that are
going to be my outputs and I've just
said the word neuron for the first time
but ultimately what when we talk about
neurons and neural networks is that you
know there's it's not really anything to
do with the human brain it's a very
rough simulation of how the human brain
does things and these internal functions
to try and figure out how to match the
inputs to the outputs you know we call
those neurons and on my output they're
like those three at the bottom are also
going to be neurons too and that's what
lends the name neural networks to this
it tends to sound a little bit
mysterious and special when we call it
like that but ultimately just think
about them as functions with randomly
initialized variables that over time
we're going to try to change the value
of those variables so that the inputs
match our desired outputs so then is
this line the model dot compiled line
and what's that going to do that's a
kind of fancy term it's not really doing
compilation the way we're turning code
into byte code as before but think about
the two parameters to this and these are
the most important part to learn in
machine learning and these are the loss
and the optimizer so the idea is the job
of these two is remember earlier on I
said it's going to randomly initialize
all those functions and if they're
randomly initialized and I pass in
something that looks like a rock there's
a one in three chance it's going to get
it right as a scissors are as a rock or
a paper or scissors so what the loss
function does is it measures the results
of all the thousands of times they do
that it figures out how well or how
badly it did and then based on that it
passes that data to the other function
which is called the optimizer function
and the optimizer function then
generates the next guess where the guess
is set to be the parameters of those 512
little functions those 512 neurons and
if we keep repeating this we'll pass our
data in we'll take a look we'll make a
guess we'll see how well or how badly we
did then based on that will optimize or
we'll make another guess and we'll
repeat repeat repeat until our guesses
get better and better and better and
that's what happens in the model dot fit
here you can see our model dot fit where
epochs epochs epochs depending on how
you pronounce it is a hundred all that's
doing is doing that cycle a hundred
times for every image take a look at the
parameters fit those parameters
take a guess measure how go to how bad
you did
and then repeats and keep going and the
optimizer then will make it better and
better and better so you can imagine the
first time through you're gonna get it
right roughly one in three times
subsequent times it's gonna get closer
and closer and closer and better and
better okay now those of us who know a
little bit about images and an image
process and go okay that's nice but it's
a little naive I'm just throwing all of
the pixels of the image and maybe a lot
of these pixels aren't even set into a
neural network and having a try to
figure out from those pixel values can I
do it a little bit smarter than that and
the answer to that is yes
and one of the ways that we can do it a
little bit smarter than that is using
something called convolutions now
convolutions is a convoluted term if you
excuse the pun but the idea behind
convolutions is if you've ever done any
kind of image processing the way like
you can sharpen images or soften images
with things like Photoshop it's exactly
the same thing so with a convolution the
idea is you take a look at every pixel
in the image so for example this picture
of a hand and I'm just looking at one of
the pictures on the finger pixels on the
fingernail and so that pixel is like
value 192 in the box on the left here so
if you take a look at every pixel in the
image and you look at its immediate
neighbors and then you get something
called a filter so which is the gray box
on the right and you apply you multiply
out the value of the pixel by the
corresponding value in the filter and
you do that for all of the pixels
neighbors to get a new value for the
pixel that's what a convolution is now
many of us if you've never done this
before you might be sitting around
thinking why on earth would I do that
well the reason for that is that when
finding convolutions and finding filters
it becomes really really good at
extracting features in an image so let
me give an example so if you look at the
image on the left here and I have apply
a filter like this one I will get the
image on the right now what has happened
here is that the image on the Left I've
thrown away a lot of the noise in the
image and I've been able to detect
vertical lines so just simply by
applying a filter like this vertical
lines are surviving through their
multiplication of the filter and then
similarly if I apply a filter like this
one horizontal lines survive and there
are lots of filters out there they can
be randomly initialized and they can be
learned that do things like picking out
items in an image like eyes or ears or
fingers or fingernails and things like
that so that's the idea behind
convolutions now the next thing is okay
if I'm going to be doing lots of
processing on my image like this and I'm
going to be doing training and I'm gonna
have to have like hundreds of filters to
try and pick out different features in
my image
that's gonna be a lot of data that I
have to deal with and wouldn't it be
nice if I could compress my images so
compression is achieved through
something called pooling and it's it's a
very very simple thing it's sometimes it
seems a very complex term to describe
something simple but when we talk about
pooling I'm going to apply for example a
2x2 pool to an image and what that's
going to do is it's going to take the
pixels two by two like if you look at my
left here if I've got 16 simulated
pixels I'm gonna take the top four in
the top left hand corner and of those
four I'm gonna pick the biggest value
and then the next four in the top right
hand corner of those four I'll pick the
biggest value and so on and so on
so what that's going to do is
effectively throw away 75% of my pixels
and just keep the maximums in each of
these 2x2 little units but the impact of
that is really interesting when we start
combining it with convolutions so if you
look at the image that I created earlier
on where I applied the filter to that
image of a person walking up the stairs
and then I pull that I get the image
that's on the right which is 1/4 the
size of the original image but not only
is it not losing any vital information
it's even enhancing some of the vital
information that came out of it so
pooling is your friend when you start
using convolutions because if you have
128 filters for example that you apply
to your image you're gonna have a
hundred and twenty eight copies of your
image you're gonna have 128 times the
data and when you're dealing with
thousands of images that's gonna slow
down your training time really fast but
pooling then really speeds it up by
shrinking the size of your image so now
when we want to start learning with a
neural network now it's a case of hey
I've got my image at the top I can start
applying convolutions to that like for
example my image might be a smiley face
and one convolution will keep it as a
smiley face another one might keep the
circle outline of a head another one
might kind of change the shape of the
head things like that and as I start
applying more and more convolutions to
these and getting some
smaller images I mean instead of me now
having a big fat image that I'm trying
to classify that I'm trying to pick out
the features of to learn from I can have
lots of little images highlighting
features in that so for example in
rock-paper-scissors my convolutions
might show in some cases five fingers or
four fingers and a thumb and I know that
that's going to be a paper or it might
show none and I know that's going to be
a rock and it then begins to make the
process of the machine learning these
much much simpler so to show this
quickly I've been putting QR codes on
these slides by the way so I've open
sourced all the code that I'm showing
here and we're talking through and this
is a QR code to a workbook where you can
train a rock-paper-scissors model for
yourself but once we do convolutions and
earlier in the slide you saw I had
multiple convolutions moving down and
this is what the code for that would
look like I just have a convolution
layer followed by a pooling another
convolution followed by pooling and
another convolution followed by a
pooling et cetera et cetera
so the impact of that and remember first
of all at the top I have my input shape
and I have my output at the bottom
whether dense equals three so I'm gonna
switch back to the demo now to see if
it's finished training and we can see it
so we started off with 33 percent
accuracy but as we went through the
epochs I just did this one I think for
15 epochs it got steadily and steadily
and steady steadily more accurate so
after 15 loops of doing this it's now
ninety six point eight three percent
accurate so as a result we can see using
these techniques using convolutions like
this we've been actually able to Train
something in just a few minutes to be
roughly 97% accurate at detecting rock
paper and scissors and if I just take a
quick plot here we can see this is a
plot of that accuracy the red line
showing the accuracy where we started at
roughly 33 percent and we're getting
close to 100% the blue line is I have a
separate data set of rock-paper-scissors
that I test it with just to see how well
it's doing and it's pretty close this I
need to do a little bit of work in
tweaking it and I can actually try an
example to show you so I'm gonna upload
a file I'm gonna choose a file from my
computer
I've nicely named that file paper so you
can guess it's a paper and if I open
that and up
that it's gonna upload that and then
it's gonna give me an output and the
output is 1 0-0 so you think I got it
wrong it detected it's a rock but
actually the my neurons here based on
the labels are in alphabetical order so
the alphabetical order would be paper
then rock then scissors so it would
actually classified that correctly by
giving me a 1 so it's actually a paper
and we can try another one at random
I'll choose a file from my machine I'll
choose a scissors and open that and run
it and again paper rock scissors so we
see it actually classified that
correctly so this workbook is online if
you want to download it and have a play
with it to do classification yourself
and to see how easy it is for you to
train a neural network to do this and
then once you have that model you can
implement that model in your
applications and maybe play rock paper
scissors in your apps can we switch back
to the slides please so just to quickly
show the idea of how convolutions really
help you with an image this is what that
model looks like when I defined it and
at the top here it might look like a
little bit of a bug at first if you're
not used to doing this but the top here
remember we said my images coming in
were 150 by 150 it's actually saying hey
I'm gonna pass out an image as 148 by
148 anybody know why is it a bug now
it's not a bug okay so the reason why is
if my filter was 3 by 3 for me to be
able to look at a pixel I have to throw
one out for me to start on the image I
have to start one pixel in and one pixel
down in order for it to have neighbors
so as a result I have to throw away all
the pixels at the top at the bottom and
either side of my image so I'm losing
one pixel on all sides so my 150 by 150
becomes a 148 by 148 and then when I
pulled that I have to each of the axes
have become 74 by 74 then through the
next iteration it becomes 36 by 36 then
17 by 17 and then 7 by 7 so if you think
about all of these 150 squared images
passing through all of these
convolutions are coming up with lots of
little 7 by 7 things and those little 7
by 7 things should be highlighting a
feature it might be a fingernail it
might be a thumb it might be shape of a
hand and then those features
that came through the convolutions are
then passed into the neural network that
we saw earlier on to generate those
parameters and then from those
parameters hopefully it would make a
guess and a really accurate guess about
something being a rocket paper or
scissors so if you prefer an IDE instead
of using collab you can do that also I
tend to really like to use pycharm for
my development any PyCharm friends here
out of interest
yeah nice a lot of you and so here's a
screenshot of PyCharm
when I was writing this
rock-paper-scissors thing before I
pasted it over to collab where you can
run it from collab so pi term was really
really nice and you can do things like
step by step debugging if we can switch
to the demo sheep machine for a moment
now I'll do a quick demo of pycharm
doing step by step debugging so here we
can see we're in rock-paper-scissors and
for example if I hit the debug I can
even set breakpoints so now I have a
breakpoint on my code so I can start
with taking a look at what's happening
in my neural network code here I'm just
like this is where I'm pre loading the
data into it and I can step through and
I could do a lot of debugging to really
make sure my neural network is working
the way that I want it to work it's one
of the things that I hear a lot from
developers when they first get started
with machine learning is that there
seems to be your models are very much a
black box you have all this Python code
for training a model and then you have
to do some rough guess work with
tensorflow being open source I can
actually step into the tensorflow code
in pie chart like I'm doing here to see
how the training is going on so help me
to debug my models and carmell later is
also going to show how something called
tensor board can be used for debugging
models and we switch back to the slides
please so with that in mind we've gone
from like really just not understanding
what's or bit just beginning to
understand what neural networks are all
about and basic hello world code to
taking a look at how we can views
something or convolutions and there's
something that sounds really complicated
and really difficult but once you start
using your se they're actually very very
easy to use particularly for image and
text classification and we saw then how
it was in just a few minutes we were
able to train a neural network to be
able to recognize rock paper and
scissors with like 97 98 percent
accuracy so that's just getting started
but now to show us how to actually
stretch the
framework and to make it real and to do
really cool and production quality stuff
Carmel is going to share with us thank
you hi so quick show of hands for how
many of you was that totally new and now
you're paddling as fast as you can to
keep your head above water
alright a fair number of you I'm gonna
go over now some of the tools and
features that tensorflow has to take you
from when you've actually got your model
to all the way through production don't
worry there is no test at the end so for
those of you who are just trying to keep
up right now track these words store
somewhere in the back of your head that
this is all available for the rest of
you where you've already got a model and
you're looking what you can form or that
you can do with it pay attention now all
right
so Lawrence went through an image
classification problem in slides we love
image classification problems because
they look nice on slides but maybe your
data isn't an image classification
problem what if you've got categorical
data or text-based data tensorflow
provides a number of tools that allow
you to take different data types and
transform them before loading them into
a machine learning model in particular
for example here we've got maybe we've
got some user click streams right we've
got a user ID now if we fed that
directly into a deep learning model our
model would expect that that is real
valued and numeric and it might think
that user number 125 has some relation
to user 126 even though in reality
that's not true so we need to be able to
take data like this and transform it
into data that our model can understand
so how do we do that well in tensorflow
one of the tools that we use extensively
inside of google our feature columns
these are configurations that allow you
to configure transformations on incoming
data so here you can see we're taking
our categorical column user ID and we're
saying hey this is a categorical column
when we pass in data for it and we don't
want the model to use it as a
categorical column we want to transform
this in this case into an embedding
right so you can do a one hot
representation here we're gonna do an
embedding that actually gets learned as
we train our model this embedding and
other columns that you have can then get
directly fed into Kerris layers so here
we have a dense features layer that
though it's going to take all these
transformations and run them when we
our data through and this feeds directly
downstream into our Karis model so that
when we pass input data through the
transformations happen before we
actually start learning from the data
and that ensures that our model is
learning what we want it to learn using
real valued numerical data and what do
you do with that layer once you've got
it in your model well in Kerris we
provide quite a few layers lawrence
talked you through convolutional layers
pooling layers those are some of the
popular ones in image models but we've
got a whole host of layers depending on
what your needs are so many that I
couldn't fit them in a single screenshot
here but there are an ends drop out
layers batch norm all sorts of sampling
layers so no matter what type of
architecture you're building whether
you're building something for your own
small use case an image classification
model whatever it is or the latest and
greatest research model there are a
number of built-in layers that are going
to make that a lot easier for you and if
you've got a custom use case that's
actually not represented in one of the
layers and maybe you've got custom
algorithms or custom functionality one
of the beauties of Carus is that it
makes it easy to subclass layers to
build in your own functionality here
we've got a point care normalization
layer this is it represents a point care
embedding this is not provided out of
the box with tensorflow but a community
member has contributed this layer to the
tensorflow add-ons repository where we
provide a number of custom special use
case layers it's both useful if you need
point care normalization but also a very
good example of how you might write a
custom layer to handle all of your needs
if we don't have that out-of-the-box for
you here you write the call method which
handles the forward pass of this layer
so you can check out the tensorflow
add-ons repository for more examples of
layers like this in fact everything in
Karis can be subclassed or almost
everything you've got metrics losses
optimizers if you need functionality
that's not provided out-of-the-box we
try to make it easy for you to build on
top of what Karis already provides while
still taking advantage of the entire
Kerris and tensorflow ecosystem so here
I'm sub-classing a model so if I need
some custom forward pass in my model I'm
able to do that easily in the call
method and I can define custom training
loops within
custom model this makes it easy to do in
this case a trivial thing like magic
multiplied by a magic number but if for
a lot of models where you need to do
something that's different than the
standard fit loop you're able to
customize in this way and still take
advantage of all of the tooling that we
provide for Karis so one of the problems
with custom models and more complicated
models is it's hard to know whether
you're actually doing what you think
you're doing and whether your model is
training one of the tools we provide for
Karis and tensorflow more broadly as
tensor board this is a visualization
tool it's web-based and it runs a server
that will take in the data as your model
train so that you can see real time epic
by epic or step-by-step how your model
is doing here you can see accuracy and
loss as the model trains and converges
and this allows you to track your model
as you train and ensure that you're
actually progressing towards convergence
anyone you're using Kerris you can also
see that you get the full graph of the
layers that you've used you can dig into
those and actually get the OP graph in
tensorflow
too and this is really helpful in
debugging to make sure that you
correctly wired your model and you're
actually building and training what you
think you are training in Kerris the way
you add this is as easy as a few lines
of code here we've got our tensor board
callback that we define we add that to
our model during training and that's
gonna write out to the logs to disk a
bunch of different metrics that then get
read in by the tensor board web GUI and
as an added bonus you get built in
performance profiling with that so one
of the tabs in tensor board is going to
show you where all of your ops are being
placed where you've got performance
bottlenecks this is extremely useful as
you begin to build larger and more
models because you will see that
performance during training can become
one of the the bottlenecks in your
process and you really want to make that
faster speaking of performance this is a
plot of how long it takes resin at fifty
one of the most popular machine learning
models for image classification resonant
52 train using one GPU don't even ask
how long it takes with one CPU because
nobody likes to sit there and wait until
it finishes but you can see that it
takes a better part of a week with one
GPU
one of the beauties of deep learning is
that it is very easily parallelizable
and so what we want to provide is
tensorflow are ways to take this
training pipeline and paralyze it the
way we do that in tensorflow 2.0 is
we're providing a series of distribution
strategies these are gonna make it very
easy for you to take your existing model
code here we've got a Karass model that
looks like many of the others you've
seen throughout this talk and we're
gonna distribute it over multiple GPUs
so here we add the mirrored strategy
with this elite these few lines of code
we're now able to distribute our model
across multiple GPUs these strategies
have been designed from the ground up to
be easy to use and to scale with lots of
different architectures and to give you
great out-of-the-box performance so what
this is actually doing here you can see
that with those few lines of code by
building our model under the strategy
scope what we've done is we've taken the
model we've copied it across all of our
different devices in this picture let's
say we've got 4 GPUs we copy our model
across those GPUs and we shard the input
data that means that you're actually
going to be processing the input in
parallel across each of your different
devices and in that way you're able to
scale model training approximately
linearly with the number of devices you
have so if you've got 4 GPUs you can run
approximately four times faster what
that ends up looking like on ResNet you
can see that we get great scaling and
just out of the box you're what you're
getting with that is that your variables
are getting are getting neared and sync
across all available devices batches are
getting pre fetched all of this goes
into making your models much more
performant during training time all
without changing code when you're using
Kerris all right and mirrored strategy
with multi GPUs is just the beginning as
you scale models as we do at Google for
example you might want to use multiple
nodes in multiple servers each of which
have their own set of GPUs you can use
the multi word mirrored strategy for
that which is going to take your model
replicate it across multiple machines
all working synchronously to train your
model mirroring variables across all of
them this allows you to train your model
at faster than ever being ever before
and
this API is still experimental as we're
developing it but in tensorflow 2.0
you'll be able to run this out of the
box and get that great performance
across large scale clusters all right so
everything I've talked about so far
falls under the heading of training
models and you will find that a lot of
milk model builders only ever think
about the training portion but if you've
got a machine learning model that you're
trying to get into production you know
that's only half the story there's a
whole other half which is well how do I
take what I've learned and actually
serve that to customers or to whoever
the end user is right in tensorflow the
way we do that is you are gonna have to
serialize your model into a saved model
this saved model becomes the serialized
format of your model that then
integrates with the rest of the
tensorflow ecosystem that allows you to
deploy that model into production so for
example we've got a number of different
libraries and utilities that can take
this saved model for tensorflow serving
we're gonna be able to take that model
and do web based serving request this is
what we use at Google for some of our
largest scale systems tensorflow lite is
for mobile development tensorflow j/s is
a web native solution for serving your
models I'm gonna go or I'm not gonna
have time to go over all of these in the
next few minutes but I will talk about
tensorflow serving and tensorflow light
a little bit more but first how do you
actually get to a saved model again in
tensorflow 2.0 this is gonna be easy and
out of the box where you're gonna take
your Karras model you call dot save and
this is gonna write out the tensorflow
saved model format this is a serialized
version of your model it includes the
entire graph and all of the variables
and weights and everything that you've
learned and it writes that out to disk
so that you can take it pass it to
somebody else let's say you can load it
back into Python you're gonna get all of
that Python objects state back as you
can see here and you could continue to
train continue to use that you could
fine-tune based on that or you could
take that model and load it into TF
serving so tensorflow serving response
to G RPC or rest requests it acts as a
front-end that takes the requests loads
them into or sends them to your model
for inference it's going to get the
result back so if you're building a web
app for our rock-paper-scissors game you
could take a picture send it to your
server the server is going to ask the
model hey what is
this send back a send back the answer
based on what the model found and in
that way you get that full round-trip
tensorflow serving is what we use
internally for many of our largest
machine learning models so it's been
optimized to have low latency and high
throughput you can check it out at 10 to
Flo org there's an entire suite of
production pipelining and processing
components that we call tensorflow
extended or tf-x you can learn more
about those at tensorflow org using that
handy-dandy QR code right there and
maybe you've got a model and you've got
your web app but really you want it on a
phone right because you want to be the
future as mobile you want to be able to
take this anywhere so tensorflow Lite is
the library that we provide for
converting your saved model into a very
tiny small footprint so that can fit on
your mobile device it can fit on
embedded devices raspberry pies edge TP
use we now run these models across a
number of different devices the way you
do this is you take that same saved
model from that same model code that you
wrote originally you use the TF light
converter which shrinks the footprint of
that model and then it can be loaded
directly onto device and this allows you
to run on device without internet
without a server in the background
whatever your model is and you can take
it take tensorflow wherever you want to
be no we run through really quickly from
some machine learning fundamentals
through building your first model all
the way through some of the tools that
tensorflow provides for taking those and
deploying those to production what do
you do now well there's a lot more out
there you can go to google dev you can
go to tensorflow org or we've got a
great number of tutorials you can go to
github this is all open source you can
see the different libraries there ask
questions send PRS we love PRS and with
that I'd like to say thank you back out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you